(générique)
---
-Bonjour, Riss.
-Bonjour.
-Ca va ?
-Ca va, ça va.
-Vous diriez que vous êtes
un garçon engagé ?
-Euh...
J'en sais trop rien,
ça dépend des jours.
-Plus ou moins ?
-Je me regarde pas
en me disant...
Je me pose pas la question
de savoir si je suis engagé.
Je me regarde pas dans une glace
pour savoir si je donne l'image
de quelqu'un d'engagé.
-C'est pas une histoire
d'image, mais ce que
vous portez dans vos tripes.
Pour moi, c'était une évidence
que vous alliez dire oui.
-On l'est sans s'en rendre compte,
en fait.
On fait de la prose
comme M. Jourdain,
on fait de l'engagement
sans s'en rendre compte.
On est engagés depuis...
Enfin, engagé, je me sens
impliqué dans ce qui
se passe autour de moi
depuis que je suis gamin.
-Donc c'est une nature.
-Oui, oui.
Y a une curiosité pour le monde
qu'il y autour de vous,
pour ce qui se passe autour de vous,
pour essayer de comprendre
ce qui se passe et essayer
de vous positionner,
"comment je me positionne
dans ce monde-là."
-Vous m'avez amené un objet
qui symbolise votre engagement.
-Vous voulez le voir
maintenant ?
-Ca vous ennuie ?
Vous me dites.
-Non, j'ai amené un numéro
du journal qui est particulier,
parce qu'il y a
des trous dedans, en fait.
C'est un journal
qui a été troué
par les balles du 7 janvier.
Et voilà, en rangeant le journal,
on a découvert
des liasses de journaux
qui avaient été traversées
par des balles.
Et en ouvrant
ces liasses, on a découvert
des morceaux de métal, comme ça.
-C'est une des balles ?
-Une des balles, oui.
-Et vous arrivez
à vivre avec cet objet ?
-Je le garde parce que...
Ca fait partie
de l'histoire du journal.
-Plus largement que ça,
ça fait partie
de notre histoire
à tous, non ?
-C'est sûr.
Mais peut-être qu'il faudrait
le montrer en public.
Des fois, je me dis
que ça mériterait d'être exposé,
pour qu'on se rende compte
de ce qu'est un journal
qui physiquement subit la violence.
Quand vous faites un journal
et que vous découvrez
des exemplaires troués,
c'est du réel.
Et c'est irréversible.
C'est l'histoire du journal.
-Quand les frères Kouachi
vous tirent dessus,
ils changent la nature
de votre engagement ?
-Non, ils changent
rien du tout.
Ils changent l'intensité
de l'engagement,
c'est-à-dire qu'on sera encore
plus engagés après.
-Ils le poussent un peu ?
Ils le changent dans le sens
où vous avez dû
prendre une place
que vous n'aviez pas.
-Oui, mais ça,
c'est des circonstances,
c'est presque secondaire.
Politiquement, ça ne change rien
à mon engagement,
si ce n'est que ça le rend
encore plus déterminé.
J'aurais tendance à dire,
plus on me tape dessus,
plus j'ai envie
de réagir aussi.
Ca ne va pas m'affaiblir,
ça va au contraire
me rendre encore plus déterminé.
-Je vous le rends,
parce que...
Je ne sais pas, j'ai un drôle
de rapport avec cet objet.
C'est impressionnant
que vous ameniez ça.
-Des fois, je me dis que les gens
ne se rendent pas vraiment compte
de ce que c'est concrètement,
que la violence.
C'est souvent un peu abstrait.
-Ca l'était pour vous,
avant de le vivre ?
On ne peut pas avoir
la même compréhension
de ce qui vous est arrivé,
même si on sait tous
ce qui s'est passé.
C'est impossible d'imaginer,
même si vous l'écrivez,
si vous le racontez.
-Oui, il y a toujours quelque chose
qui sera irracontable.
On peut raconter beaucoup de choses,
décrire beaucoup de choses,
mais vous vous heurtez à un mur,
un plafond de verre.
Vous ne pouvez pas aller au-delà
d'un certain niveau
d'explication ou de transmission.
-Il y a des choses,
quand même,
qu'on peut transformer
ou qu'on dit sans vouloir le dire.
Par exemple, vous n'avez
jamais arrêté de dessiner.
Vous avez dessiné à l'hôpital
avec votre mauvaise main.
Vous êtes blessé.
Vous utilisez la main
avec laquelle
vous ne dessinez pas.
Vous n'arrêtez jamais.
Vous ne vous êtes jamais dit...
Vous ne vous êtes pas demandé
si vous vouliez vraiment continuer
ou arrêter ?
-C'était une question
plus d'interrogation
sur mes capacités physiques.
Quand vous êtes à l'hôpital,
vous êtes au fond du trou.
On s'épuise vite.
Je me demandais dans quel état
je serais dans six mois
ou un an.
Ca ne remettait pas en cause
la détermination
de ce que je voulais faire.
Tout ce qui nous arrivait
ne faisait que confirmer
tout ce à quoi on croyait
et pour lequel on se battait,
toute l'équipe de Charlie, avant.
De manière tragique,
ça validait toutes nos convictions.
Le fait que,
sans qu'on s'en aperçoive,
des nouvelles formes
de tyrannie se mettent en place,
apparaissent, et essayent
de s'imposer aux autres.
Quand on essayait
d'expliquer ça au moment
du procès des caricatures,
les gens pensaient
que c'était uniquement
un problème de dessinateurs
anticléricaux.
Ils n'ont pas compris
que ça annonçait quelque chose
de plus profond qui allait
toucher tout le monde.
On l'a vu ensuite,
avec la vague d'attentats.
-Il est très vieux,
ce point que vous soulevez.
En 72, Brassens est attaqué.
Il en a marre
et il décide d'écrire
une des rares chansons
politiques qu'il a écrites.
Dans cette chanson,
il dit qu'il faut se méfier
de toutes les idéologies.
On l'écoute.
-Des idées réclamant
Le fameux sacrifice
Les sectes de tout poil
En offrent des séquelles
Et la question se pose
Aux victimes novices
Mourir pour des idées
C'est bien beau
Mais lesquelles ?
Et comme toutes sont
Entre elles ressemblantes
Quand il les voit venir
Avec leur gros drapeau
Le sage en hésitant
Tourne autour du tombeau
"Mourons pour des idées
D'accord
"Mais de mort lente
"D'accord
Mais de mort lente"
-Vous en pensez quoi,
de cette chanson ?
-Je me demande si
elle n'est pas un peu datée,
s'il n'a pas...
Si ce n'est pas
une chanson écrite
dans la veine
d'un certain pacifisme
des années 20, 30.
Effectivement, pour un drapeau,
on envoyait des gens
se faire massacrer.
Il a ça en tête.
-C'est antimilitariste.
C'est aussi pour dire :
"Attention..."
-C'est aussi contre
des formes de nationalisme
comme ce que l'Europe
a pu connaître
dans les années 20 ou les années 30.
Mais...
Peut-être qu'on est
à une autre époque.
Ce n'est plus vraiment
des nationalismes
"à l'ancienne",
même si on voit beaucoup de partis
xénophobes en Europe émerger
en Hongrie, en Pologne.
Il y a encore beaucoup
de nationalismes.
Mais je ne pense pas qu'on soit
dans les années 30 non plus.
-Mais mourir
pour des idées, ça, oui ?
C'est bien ?
Il faut, on peut, on doit ?
-Le problème, c'est :
quelles idées ?
-Les siennes,
celles auxquelles on croit.
-C'est quelque chose
qui peut être invoqué aussi
par des fascistes,
par des tyrans.
-On va en parler,
d'ailleurs.
-C'est trop large,
comme définition.
-Il y a de nouveaux
dessinateurs qui ont rejoint
la rédac de Charlie.
Ils sont engagés ?
-J'espère.
S'ils sont venus
vers le journal
sans qu'on les force...
-Quand on bosse chez Charlie,
il faut avoir
un gros sens de l'humour
et de la dérision.
Il faut aussi avoir
un sens de l'engagement.
-Il faut être politisé.
C'est plus précis
que l'engagement.
Il faut s'intéresser à la politique,
à l'histoire, à la culture.
Souvent, l'humour, la satire,
fait référence
à beaucoup de choses.
Souvent, les dessins sont mal
compris parce qu'il y a un manque
de culture politique
et de culture tout court.
C'est vrai que le jeu
dans la satire,
c'est des références.
On joue avec un tas de choses :
des références graphiques,
historiques,
politiques,
qu'il faut avoir.
Pour faire des dessins comme ça,
il faut les avoir.
Un dessinateur satirique
à Charlie, il est politisé.
-Vous les trouvez
courageux, vos jeunes collègues
qui vous rejoignent ?
Ce n'est pas anodin,
de bosser pour Charlie.
-Oui, mais...
Ce n'est pas "courageux".
Je les trouve,
comment dire...
Ils ont la même...
Le même enthousiasme
que celui qu'on avait en 92
avec Charb ou Luz.
On voulait faire plein de trucs
sans très bien savoir
ce qu'on allait faire.
On avait envie de faire
un journal et de se marrer,
de découvrir le monde
à travers ce journal,
de faire partager ça aux lecteurs.
Il y a le même enthousiasme.
-Il est là, intact.
-Il est là, renouvelé,
à nouveau là.
-Le temps passe.
Est-ce que parfois,
vous oubliez ?
-Je peux oublier des détails,
mais je n'oublie pas...
Je pardonne pas,
mais je n'oublie pas non plus...
Des émotions furtives...
Des ambiances, des atmosphères
liées à ce moment-là.
C'est des choses...
Je ne sais pas si...
J'ai peut-être une mémoire.
sensorielle aiguë
mais je peux me souvenir
de l'ambiance d'un moment.
Pas seulement des faits,
mais...
L'électricité
du moment.
C'est vrai que je...
C'est difficile...
C'est pas possible
d'oublier
cette fébrilité...
..que l'on ressent
quand on voit
quelqu'un qui arrive
devant vous avec une arme.
D'un seul coup,
tout est suspendu.
Le temps est suspendu et...
..vous savez que vous allez
basculer dans quelque chose.
Donc ça, j'ai ça en mémoire,
pas seulement visuellement
mais physiquement.
J'ai une mémoire physique
des choses.
-Vous employez le mot
"oubli" exprès.
Euh....
J'ai le sentiment
que vous avez peur qu'on oublie,
que nous, on oublie.
Quand vous m'avez dédicacé
votre livre
et que je l'ai reçu,
il y avait écrit :
"Pour ne rien oublier."
-Pour tenter de donner
aux lecteurs des outils
pour ne pas trop oublier,
en tout cas.
C'est sûr, le temps passe.
Inévitablement,
comme tout événement
politique ou historique,
à un moment donné, voilà,
vous avez des...
..des jeunes, aujourd'hui,
je discutais avec une personne,
qui ne savent pas trop
ce qu'est le 11 septembre 2001.
La personne m'a dit
que sa fille ne sait pas
ce qu'est le 11 septembre 2001.
On a l'impression qu'aujourd'hui,
les jeunes, en général,
ne connaissent que les événements
qu'ils ont connu dans leur vie.
Si ça a eu lieu avant,
ça n'existe pas.
-Oui.
-Ou alors, ils doivent
faire un effort
ou il faut leur mettre
sous le nez.
Un jour, peut-être
que le 7 janvier,
comme tout ce qui
s'est passé en 2015,
ça deviendra un événement...
..antérieur aux existences
nouvelles qui vont arriver.
-Ca sortira
de quelque chose de concret.
Vous avez
presque plus peur de nous
que des terroristes ?
Plus peur de la trahison
qu'on pourrait faire, nous,
alors que c'est vraiment
dans nos vies à tous ?
-C'est sûr que les gens
qui ont vécu cet événement
ne l'oublieront pas.
Mais, euh...
Les personnes qui vont naître
dans 1, 2 ou 3 ans...
-Ils sauront que des gens
sont morts en France
car ils dessinaient...
-Peut-être ou peut-être pas.
C'est pas sûr
que les gens qui naîtront
dans les générations à venir
s'y intéresseront.
-C'est grave,
qu'ils ne le sachent pas ?
-C'est grave
qu'ils ne le sachent pas,
comme d'autres choses.
Il n'y a pas que ça.
C'est grave
de ne pas bien connaître
l'histoire de la société
dans laquelle on émerge.
Je pense.
-Oui.
-On parlait de l'engagement.
Quand j'étais gamin ou ado,
j'étais préoccupé
de comprendre là où j'étais
mais aussi le passé,
ce qu'il y avait avant.
-Ca vient d'où, ça ?
-Je pense que
pour se sentir bien,
il faut...
Il faut,
comment dire, avoir...
Il faut savoir où on est,
trouver sa place
dans le temps
et dans l'espace.
-Il n'y a pas un enfant...
Enfin, certainement
car vous l'avez fait,
c'est peu commun de se dire :
"Moi, enfant,
je suis dans ce monde,
"que se passait-il avant ?
Qu'est ce qui se racontait avant ?
"Qu'ont-ils vécu avant ?"
Tout le monde
n'a pas cette démarche-là.
-Ce n'est pas une démarche,
c'est le fait d'écouter les adultes
qui avaient des choses à dire,
qui en avaient vécu.
Les générations d'adultes
à cette époque-là
avaient connu la guerre,
avaient connu des guerres.
Les plus anciens avaient connu
la 1re Guerre mondiale.
Autour de nous,
on avait des gens
qui avaient fait
la guerre de 14,
qui étaient estropiés.
Plus tard, il y avait ceux
qui avaient fait la guerre 39-45,
et qui avaient
des choses à raconter.
-Vous aviez un grand-père,
une grand-mère qui racontait ?
-Oui, ou je me souviens,
j'avais ma camarade
de classe...
Elle...
C'était...
Son père était résistant.
On habitait Moulins
et elle me racontait que...
A Moulins, il y avait
la ligne de démarcation,
et son père
la traversait à la nage
pour passer de la zone libre
à la zone occupée.
Donc, voilà...
On avait ce genre
de témoignages.
Ce n'était pas
des témoignages historiques
mais de gens
avec qui vous viviez.
Donc évidemment,
comment ne pas...
Comment ne pas s'intéresser
et comment...
..à ce qui s'est passé
avant vous ?
-C'est dur de...
Je vois bien que pour vous,
c'est presque évident,
que ça va de soi,
et que c'est étonnant
que ça ne soit pas
communément répandu.
Mais c'est parfois dur
de penser,
comme en ce moment.
Je suis admirative
de vos éditos.
Je me demande comment
vous faites pour avoir
un avis clair sur tout.
C'est dur de penser.
Qu'est-ce que
je pense du voile,
en tant que femme,
l'interdire ou l'autoriser ?
Que fait-on de ces mômes
emmenés par leurs parents
en Syrie, qui errent
dans des camps,
faut-il qu'ils reviennent ?
Je n'en sais rien.
Que fait-on des djihadistes
qui ont fini
leur peine de prison ?
C'est dur de penser.
Qu'est-ce que...
Comment vous aimeriez que...
-Ce que vous décrivez,
c'est la politique.
-Oui, bien sûr.
-Dès qu'on essaye
de comprendre
la vie en société,
la vie en collectivité,
ça devient tout de suite
très compliqué.
-Oui.
-Ce sera jamais simple.
Pas seulement ces problèmes-là,
mais bien d'autres.
Donc, si...
On parlait d'engagement,
si on ne prend pas
son courage à deux mains
et qu'on ne se coltine pas
cette difficulté,
d'abord, je pense
qu'on sera submergés...
..on sera écrasés
par les événements,
on sera balayés.
Si on ne veut pas être balayés,
il faut, au moins,
comprendre
ce qu'il y a autour
pour trouver
la bonne position,
pour ne pas se faire,
justement, effacer...
Pour exister, en fait.
-Oui.
-Si vous ne comprenez pas
votre environnement,
vous n'existez pas, quoi.
-Et si vous ne trouvez pas
votre place, aussi.
Je vous dis ça parce que,
et ça revient à ce qu'on disait,
je pensais à ce film incroyable
de Louis Malle, "Lacombe Lucien",
l'histoire de ce môme
un peu perdu,
il veut rentrer
dans la Résistance,
les résistants le refusent
alors il va à la Gestapo.
Il veut trouver
une place, absolument.
Il ne la trouve pas
chez les résistants
donc il va la trouver
chez les méchants.
Trouver sa place
à n'importe quel prix,
est-ce que ça justifie tout ?
-J'ai jamais dit
qu'il fallait trouver sa place
à n'importe quel prix.
Trouver sa place
pour, euh...
Déjà,
pour ne pas être...
Pour ne pas
se faire écraser, aussi.
Trouver sa place,
c'est aussi trouver
la place des autres.
Notre place existe
aussi avec les autres.
Donc, c'est tenir compte
des autres.
Donc, ça vous oblige
à prendre en compte...
..la collectivité,
ce qu'on appelle les autres.
C'est peut-être ça
qui vous empêche de faire
des mauvais choix,
comme Lacombe Lucien.
Si on prend pas assez
en compte
le collectif, on s'égare.
-Quand on dit
"je suis Charlie",
ça engage à quoi ?
-Pour ceux qui disent ça ?
-Oui.
-Il faut leur demander.
-Vous, vous lisez quoi
quand quelqu'un vous le dit ?
-J'irais pas jusqu'à dire
"prouve-le-moi", mais...
-Mais on l'entend,
ça se voit dans vos yeux.
Tout ce que vous êtes
nous envoie ça :
"Prouvez-le-nous,
ayez du courage,
"soyez à la hauteur."
Vous êtes très exigeant
avec nous.
-"Je suis Charlie",
ce n'est pas une parole
qu'on doit dire à la légère
parce que
faire un journal comme Charlie,
on le voit...
Quand on regarde
l'histoire du journal,
même si c'est un journal...
..facile d'accès,
avec de l'humour,
ce dont parle Charlie,
ce ne sont pas
des sujets légers.
Ce n'est pas un journal léger
même si la forme peut le sembler.
Quand on met le nez dedans
et qu'on veut s'investir
dans Charlie,
il faut assumer aussi...
..cet engagement.
Quand on dit
"je suis Charlie",
ça ne doit pas
être un slogan à la mode.
C'est un engagement,
que de dire ça.
-Vous le demandez à ceux
qui vous rejoignent ?
Aux jeunes dessinateurs ?
Ils ont 20 ans pour la plupart.
-Je ne leur demande rien
car je n'ai pas à exiger d'eux.
S'ils sont là...
-C'est qu'ils le sont.
-Voilà, ils le sont.
C'est des choses
qui n'ont pas besoin d'être
formulées de manière explicite.
C'est presque...
Comment dire ?
Une sensation, on se comprend.
On se comprend, voilà.
C'est un peu comme ça que...
..que moi, j'ai...
..j'ai découvert Charlie
en 92, finalement.
Même si on était avec
des dessinateurs plus âgés,
l'âge n'avait pas d'importance.
C'est ce qui était formidable.
On ressentait quasiment
les mêmes choses.
Il n'y avait pas
de différence d'âge.
C'est un peu comme
quand une année scolaire débute,
on ne connaît pas bien
les gamins de sa classe,
et au bout d'un moment,
par attirance,
il y a des affinités,
on va vers les copains...
-On se reconnaît.
-Ca crée une bande.
Voilà.
-Il paraît que vous adorez
les westerns, c'est vrai ?
-Pas plus que ça.
-Ah bon ?
Menteur.
-Non, pas plus que ça.
Des fois, j'en regarde
par curiosité.
C'est presque
des documents, les westerns.
-Ah oui ?
-Oui, c'est une manière de faire
du cinéma qui a un peu disparu.
Voilà, c'est...
C'est une vision du monde
un peu particulière,
les westerns.
-Oui, j'en ai trouvé
un très étonnant,
qui date de 1956,
c'est un film de John Ford.
Vous avez le titre ?
C'est la référence du western,
"La prisonnière du désert",
avec John Wayne.
Regardez, on dirait
qu'il parle de vous.
*-Cela pourrait commencer
comme un conte.
Il y avait une fois un homme
que l'on devait
craindre et respecter,
un homme
à la volonté indomptable,
aux résolutions violentes,
dont l'histoire
est rude et attachante.
Voici le roman de sa vie.
*(musique épique)
John Wayne, dans le rôle
de Ethan Edwards,
campe un personnage
d'une trempe peu commune.
Guidé par son courage,
il accomplit des actes
que l'esprit humain
a peine à concevoir.
Jamais il ne se prend
pour un martyr,
jamais il ne se prend
pour un héros.
*-Je te promets
qu'on la retrouvera.
Je te le promets.
*-Voici le récit
des actions de cet homme
implacable qui ne connaît point
le repos, de cet être passionné.
C'est l'histoire
d'un peuple qui s'attaque
à une terre hostile
et des pionniers
qui bâtissent une nation.
-"Jamais il ne se prend
pour un martyr,
"pour un héros."
Ca pourrait être vous ?
-Je ne sais pas,
je ne crois pas.
C'est du cinéma.
Même si c'est John Ford,
c'est le haut du panier.
Mais non, il ne faut pas non plus...
Faut pas romancer les choses.
Voilà.
C'est bien dans les films,
mais la vie, c'est pas comme ça.
-C'est pas comme ça ?
-Non.
-La vie, c'est comment ?
-Je ne sais pas, c'est...
C'est plus terre à terre,
moins romantique,
c'est parfois plus décevant.
Et puis,
il n'y a pas de scénario.
On connaît...
Un film, on sait comment
ça commence,
comment ça avance,
comment ça se termine.
Donc...
Je ne sais pas
si on peut dire
que la vie se déroule
comme le scénario d'un film.
Quand je vois l'histoire
du journal,
tout était imprévisible
depuis 25 ans.
Des fois, je me dis :
"Qu'est-ce qui va encore
nous arriver ?"
Ce n'est pas un film.
-Peut-être le meilleur.
Le meilleur est encore
à venir, toujours.
-Ou le pire, je ne sais pas.
-Il faut se dire
que le pire est passé, non ?
-Des fois, je n'en sais rien.
-Vous êtes inquiet ?
-Je dirais
qu'il faut être vigilant.
Voilà.
On ne peut pas être...
On ne peut pas être,
comment dire,
après tout ça,
on peut pas être léger ou...
Voilà.
Superficiel.
Il faut tenir compte
de ce qui s'est passé.
-Vous avez une phrase juste
et très forte.
"La liberté, c'est une décision,
tous les jours à chaque instant.
"Si on est dans le confort,
"on ne peut pas être libre."
C'est extrêmement vrai,
mais ça ne fait pas du tout rêver.
Mais du tout.
-Si, parce que c'est exaltant.
C'est...
D'abord, ça vous donne un objectif
que beaucoup de gens
n'ont pas dans la vie.
Parfois, on se demande
ce que les gens
ont pour objectif
quand on voit aujourd'hui...
Pas seulement aujourd'hui,
mais on a l'impression
qu'on propose aux gens
de consommer, d'acheter,
on a l'impression
que c'est uniquement
dans la consommation
qu'ils se sentent vivants.
Alors qu'être libre,
c'est...
Beaucoup plus difficile.
Vous pouvez
vous affranchir
de beaucoup de choses.
C'est plus exigeant,
mais c'est comme une épreuve
permanente qui,
quand vous y arrivez,
est assez satisfaisante.
-Vous êtes libre ?
-J'essaye de l'être le plus
possible avec mes maigres moyens.
On n'est jamais vraiment libre
à 100 %.
-Vous êtes très contraint.
Vous vivez sous surveillance
en permanence.
Votre liberté a été
atrophiée ou pas du tout ?
Elle est dans la tête ?
-Ce qui est vital,
c'est ce qu'on a dans la tête.
La liberté d'aller et devenir,
elle peut être
entravée, mais elle n'est pas
non plus totalement annulée.
-Mais vous adoriez faire
des reportages.
Vous ne pouvez plus le faire ?
-Ce n'est pas impossible,
mais c'est compliqué.
C'est vrai que quand je faisais
des reportages
à l'étranger, le plaisir,
c'était d'être seul,
nulle part,
à l'autre bout du monde.
Mais c'est vrai que c'est difficile
d'être seul, maintenant.
-L'engagement, ça s'enseigne ?
-Ce n'est pas l'engagement,
c'est le sens
de l'engagement
qu'on doit enseigner.
-Le courage ?
-Non, c'est pourquoi on s'engage.
On en vient à ce que je disais,
c'est politique.
Vous voulez vivre
dans quelle société ?
Quand vous posez ça comme question,
le reste vient après.
-Vous avez conscience
que vous avez pris une place
très singulière dans nos vies ?
Vous n'en demandiez pas tant.
Vous avez pris conscience de ça ?
-Non.
-Du tout ?
-Non, je....
Je suis un peu étonné,
des fois,
de certaines réactions,
qui sont chaleureuses,
mais qui c'est vrai,
des fois, sont déconcertantes.
Mais c'est...
C'est pas la question
de savoir si c'est agréable,
c'est presque un peu gênant
d'être vu comme ça.
-Votre vie vous échappe.
Vous êtes un trésor,
un emblème, pour d'autres,
vous êtes une cible.
Votre vie vous échappe ?
-Je pense que...
On discutait de ça au journal
il n'y a pas très longtemps.
Quand on fait un dessin
ou quand on écrit un texte,
ce qui est intéressant,
c'est ce que vous ne maîtrisez pas.
Vous laissez exprimer quelque chose
de vous-même que vous ne voyez pas.
C'est le plus intéressant.
Dans la vie, c'est pareil.
Vous faites des choses,
et à la limite,
votre vie, comment dire,
je ne veux pas dire
qu'elle ne vous appartient plus,
mais ce n'est pas forcément
ce à quoi vous pensez
qui intéresse le plus
les gens autour de vous.
Mais c'est comme ça.
Il faut accepter
de se dévoiler et d'être...
Et que les gens
s'emparent de vous aussi.
A partir du moment
où on fait un métier public,
je savais en publiant
mes premiers dessins
à La grosse Bertha en 91
que j'allais être jugé.
C'est comme si on montrait
son cul aux passants.
Les gens vont s'approprier
vos dessins, vous juger,
sévèrement,
"c'est de la merde",
mais si vous n'acceptez pas ça,
il ne faut pas faire un métier
où on s'exprime en public.
Voilà.
-A ceux qui pensent que vous êtes
austère et exigeant,
vous dites quoi ?
Qu'ils ont raison ?
-J'en sais trop rien.
Ce n'est pas à moi
de répondre à cette question.
-Pourquoi vous riez ?
-Austère et exigeant...
Dans ce métier,
il faut être exigeant.
Ca, c'est sûr et certain.
-Le 7 janvier 2015,
vous vous êtes vu mourir,
vous alliez mourir.
Et vous n'êtes pas mort.
Généralement,
les gens qui échappent
à la mort changent
quelque chose dans la vie
ou eux-mêmes.
Et vous ?
-Qu'est-ce qui change,
je ne sais pas si...
Je ne sais pas
si beaucoup de choses
ont changé fondamentalement.
C'est plus après
une sensation de la vie
qui n'est plus la même,
puisqu'avant de vivre
ce genre d'expérience,
on est un peu inconscient
de la chance
qu'on a d'être vivant
et du luxe
qu'on a d'être vivant.
Vivant, c'est-à-dire
de jouir de la vie,
tout vous semble normal,
tout vous semble dû.
Après ça, on sait encore plus
que rien ne vous est dû.
La vie ne vous est pas due,
la liberté ne vous est pas due.
Ca vous rend peut-être
encore plus exigeant.
Il ne faut pas gâcher sa vie
à faire n'importe quoi
ou des choses inutiles.
Même si
parfois ça fait du bien
de faire des choses futiles,
on ne peut pas
en remplir sa vie.
-Il y a une phrase
que vous avez écrite.
Vous dédiez votre livre,
et cette phrase va s'inscrire,
"aux innocents,
"vivants, morts ou fous."
D'où sort cette phrase ?
-C'est moi qui l'ai écrite.
-Je me doute bien.
Mais c'est...
"Aux innocents,
vivants, morts ou fous".
-Innocents,
parce que je pense que...
C'était difficilement
supportable après le 7 janvier
d'entendre des gens
qui nous rendaient
responsables de notre sort.
Moi, je dis
qu'on n'est responsables
et coupables de rien.
Il faut marteler
"innocents".
Quand vous sortez de là
et que vous affirmez
que vous êtes innocent,
vous êtes entouré de gens...
..morts, vivants,
et puis d'autres
qui peut-être vont devenir fous
ou qui peuvent
être menacés par la folie.
C'est un peu les trois catégories
de vies qui vous entourent.
Les vivants,
les morts et les fous.
-Je sais que vous êtes vivant.
Vous avez peur
de devenir fou ?
-Des fois, je me suis posé
la question.
Parce que...
Parce que c'est difficile
de reprendre sa place
dans la vie
alors qu'autour de vous,
autant de vies
ont été détruites
et que ces vies faisaient
partie de la vôtre.
Il y a une partie
de ma vie qui a disparu.
Qu'est-ce qu'il vous reste ?
Il faut retrouver un équilibre,
il faut se réinventer
un équilibre
après un tel désastre.
-Si c'était à refaire,
Riss ?
-Refaire quoi ?
-Je ne sais pas.
-Je ne me pose jamais
cette question.
Il faut faire les choses
comme on pense
qu'on doit les faire
au moment où on les fait.
Le plus honnêtement possible,
en se disant :
"J'assume, j'assumerai
ce que je fais,
"en n'ayant pas de regrets
"et en essayant
de ne pas se tromper."
On peut toujours se tromper,
mais en essayant de se tromper
le moins possible.
-Merci beaucoup.
-C'est moi.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
(générique)
---